what up space fam goes in here from
anime up pro we're back at it again to
discuss the latest absolutely crazy
chapter of the dragon ball super manga
i've been getting amazing feedback on
these chapter reviews so thank you all
for that
and to keep the dragon ball super train
going the best thing you could do is
turn that like button blue and share
this video with any cultured saiyans you
know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe this
is crucial hit that notification bell
and select
all or you will miss future dragon ball
super videos now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all
my friends this was one amazing chapter
i've been noticing that these one
chapter a month
manga like dragon ball super and boruto
are hella fast paced
which in part makes up for the fact that
we gotta wait a full month to read them
and this chapter was no different
right away we picked up where the last
chapter left off with merus
and moro about the fight and we proceed
to jump into the fight super quick
not too much dilly daddling at all but
i'm getting a bit ahead of myself the
chapter is called meruses resolve
suggesting that this will be a primarily
meros focused chapter
where he will in all likelihood end up
being the mvp
we got angel hype we got moral hype we
got all the hype we could rightfully
expect
at first jaco questions where meru's his
fellow galactic patrol officer has been
and we get an obligatory we're all
totally doomed from jocko
who understandably doesn't think his
friend can do anything tomorrow
because he doesn't know that he's an
angel merus is as confident as
ever though and he makes it clear that
he is not here to steal goku's thunder
as i mentioned in my last review i
didn't expect merus to beat moro
that would be kind of pointless cause we
all know angels are op
but rather i said he would serve as a
distraction so that our boys could get
healed
and come back for round two we haven't
even seen mastered ultra instinct yet
and we are totally gonna see it in this
arc before it's through
those are definitely my thoughts at
least but yeah merus doesn't say he's
come to kick butt
just that he's here to finish up goku's
training which is ongoing obviously
since he has yet to master mastered
ultra instinct meros makes sure that
everyone who's been injured has been
transported somewhere they can be healed
however he also knows that moro can
track people so he decides that he'll
have to buy some time
thus his intention is clear from the
outset he's here to serve as a
distraction
and help advance goku's training as soon
as merus goes in for the attack
moro pretty much knows what's up this
early on he guesses that he's some sort
of deity or
god i've been mentioning lately how much
i appreciate the nods to earlier dragon
ball moments
and merus uses a power pole to fight in
the beginning
just like the one goku used to use and
he uses it to deliver one of the most
satisfying hits i've seen in a while
it's a beauty of a moment
and the recently smug moro just gets
absolutely
nailed by a galactic patrol officer no
less
moro is not out cold though and does
cushion his fall
he smiles in a demented villain sort of
way as he wipes blood from his lips
and that is what we want to see in a
good villain a dude who gets excited by
the prospect of a strong opponent
jocko is shocked at how well meadows is
doing and wonders if he was always that
strong
in the meantime we jump to where dende
is gonna heal everyone
last chapter i mentioned the possibility
of beerus and whis being here and
indeed they are merus is not acting
secretly and on his own since the other
two clearly came with him i always
appreciate seeing
beerus and whis and beerus straight up
says he's sick of doing favors for rz
boys
but i mean he'd probably be bored if he
wasn't getting involved
yes there's the food but beerus is also
a tunde type
in my view where he acts like he doesn't
like helping but in all honesty
he probably does enjoy having made these
new friends beerus as usual wants to
rush up to bulma's for some delicious
earth food and as always
he tries to convince us that the food is
what it's all about
and that's why he saves our guys they
mention merus
and how he's not with them but don't
seem too concerned that he stayed behind
then they commented how our boy goku has
god level ki
now and proceeds to heal him first he
manages to do so real quick from our
perspective and i'm not complaining
sometimes i feel like i'm still a child
waiting for goku to be healed on namek
so he can join the battle already
goku quickly figures out what verus is
up to and tells us that
and i quote any angel who fights for
real outside of training is doomed to
disappear end quote
in a sense it is quite similar to angels
of death from death note who are
supposed to be
impartial and if they choose to save a
human's life they disappear from
existence
in this case merus has chosen to save
the universe in general
and our z fighters in particular thus
goku leaves the others
in dende's care and rushes off to the
battle back to the fight between morrow
and our angel
and morrow actually starts getting the
upper hand merus is still not going full
out but morrow is good enough to be able
to punish him for holding back
he kicks merus's weapon right out of his
hands and headbutts him just like a real
goat man merus gets his staff back but
just in time to block a punch and he's
sweating moro
even notices that he's holding back his
power in part by relying on a tool
goku then arrives and meadows is as
happy as moro is shocked to see him all
fine and healthy
after being on the brink of death here
we get a very interesting moment
as merus points out he's still intact
meaning that he didn't fight for real
outside of training
he held back so he'd be fine if he
stopped fighting right there
everything seems to work out perfectly
goku taps into his unmastered ultra
instinct form
and begins to fight moro moro seems to
have no trouble keeping up with goku's
ultra instinct sign form though
and whis even tells beerus that he very
much doubts that goku can win harsh
words but accurate as we jump to goku
receiving a solid blow
and reverting back to his normal form
goku feels discouraged and like he's
making no progress
but meru smiles saying it's the opposite
his training worked and all he's missing
is one last push to trigger it then
morrow goes to copy merus's ability
a brilliant idea in theory but meru
starts to get more serious and tears off
his arm with one swing of his staff
at this point merus has done more than
enough as an angel he has given goku
another chance
but since goku still hasn't mastered
ultra instinct
meros decides he'll need to seal off
moro's copying power
we learned from beerus that merus is in
fact using angel powers now
and beerus and whis decide to head to
the fight so as not to get the grand
priest mad
meadows in addition to fighting gives us
more interesting info about the angels
being an angel means maintaining a
neutral position outside of good and
evil
so even if the universe is ravaged and
destroyed an angel is just supposed to
sit back and watch
keep in mind as he's having this
conversation he's also
wrecking moral and breaking sealing off
his copying abilities
i think it's pretty hilarious how this
conversation is being had
in between short bursts of him kicking
butt he tells goku that in the galactic
patrol job
a sense of justice blossomed inside him
and you know during these emotional i've
changed
speeches that something bad is coming
for the character making them
funnily enough merus says that the
galactic patrol are helpless on the
universal scale
and i'm sure we've all thought that when
we compared joko to goku and vegeta what
meros respects is the fact that these
officers even though they're weaker than
the criminals
bravely continue to struggle they do
their duty living life according to
their ideals even if they may have to
pay the ultimate price
it's the bravery that meadows respects
and angels usually wouldn't have to
worry about anything like
that since they're so strong and since
they're not supposed to protect the
galaxy per se
but stay neutral interestingly enough
meadows turns his staff into a gun
and shoots the copy ability right out of
morrow's other hand
and now you can really see the shock and
fear in morrow's face
and just when we think that morrow is in
serious trouble merus
starts to become see-through as he tells
goku that he's realized that peace in
the galaxy
is worth hanging on to aka it's worth
fighting for
and even dying for and then he even says
that goku
strengthened that resolve even further
goku wants him to stop but merus
proclaims his final attack
and even we says that they are too late
beerus suggests that whis
purposely left meadows behind knowing
that he would do this
even though they may get in trouble with
the grand priest because of it it seems
whis respected marous's wishes and
ideals enough to let him violate angel
rules
as merus is rushing in for the last
attack we get a flashback cementing the
connection that goku and merus developed
during their time together i love this
conversation that they had
meadows tries to praise goku for saving
the world time after time
and goku being goku replies he just
wants to fight the strongest guys
and they tend to be villains and when
menos tries to question why he doesn't
kill them
goku responds that if they get stronger
he'll just get stronger and stop them
again
until they perhaps joined the good guys
one day and that's happened with many
including piccolo and vegeta
merus then tries to frame this as
reforming criminals like the galactic
patrol
but goku says that he's giving him too
much credit he just thinks this way is
more exciting
i absolutely love goku's humbleness and
i love how he doesn't take any of this
stuff too seriously
some people would go around thinking
that they are heroes of justice and have
a huge self-righteous ego
if they were goku but he resists this at
every turn
saying he just wants to fight strong
guys i absolutely love it
and this conversation beautifully
captures why i love goku as a character
too
and not only does he inspire me he
clearly inspired meadows too
back to the future and we get mehrus
easily going through
everything moro can throw at him until
he gets to him and delivers another
satisfying hit
in the form of a punch right to his
forehead he cracks the stone on his head
just like he cracked and sealed the
stones in his hands
and sends him flying we can see the pain
in goku's face as meru smiles
while disappearing forever he clearly
doesn't regret bossing up
and sacrificing his life like many
humans do
but in a way him being an angel makes it
even more special because he was so
powerful
godly and immortal compared to humans he
could have just chilled for eternity
while enjoying tasty treats but he
decided to throw it all away
for goku and for his own sense of
justice for his ideals
and those kinds of dudes are the dudes
that live on even after they're dead
on our backs and in our hearts mad
respect for meadows was definitely the
mvp of this chapter his final words are
that goku will not fall tomorrow nor to
anyone else
and he also mentioned that at his
current level if he achieved
ultra instinct it will be far more
stable than before
thus meadows leaves us with the idea
that goku will be stronger than ever
and use that power to defeat moro who
has been significantly nerfed now by
merus
and can no longer copy op abilities his
final wish is for goku to protect this
exciting universe that they both
love unlike with other deaths merus
can't be wished back with the dragon
balls making his sacrifice all the more
brave and commendable
although we send virus remain pretty
stoic about his disappearance
we just see goku's back and he seems to
be radiating a certain aura in my view
it's pretty clear what this looks like
this amazing hype image of goku from
behind is suggesting that goku
has received the push that merus was
talking about
the push that will let him use mastered
ultra instinct
and merus suggested that this time it
would be more stable which means he'll
probably be able to access it like other
forms as well
the hype is real and it seems like the
time for mastered ultra instinct versus
moro
has finally arrived yes we can't be sure
if it'll happen right next chapter but
it definitely seems that way
especially when we take the fast pacing
into account we'll see what kind of role
vegeta may or may not play
in this upcoming battle but i would be
shocked if goku doesn't go mastered
ultra instinct since merus
and the story pretty much assured us
that he will and that is it for this
chapter review mvp angel kicking butt
and vanishing and goku's hype
back and heavy mastered ultra instinct
foreshadowing that pretty much sums up
this great chapter
let me know what you thought of it and
what you expect to happen next if you
enjoyed the video and want to keep the
dragon ball super train going the best
thing you could do is turn that like
button blue like vegeta's hair
and share this video with any cultured
saiyans you know if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell and select all or
you will miss future dragon ball super
videos
i also want to thank all of you because
the channel has been growing faster than
ever and it's
unreal we passed 900 000 subscribers and
are actually approaching 1 million
subscribers
and it's all thanks to you guys and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon who helped make
videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one-tier patrons
the ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and grata alolan atem
the world acquired respect but they
heffa jonathan kang brandon of isles
papa smurf
emperor otaku thomas jones kin mono and
admiral and our pro hero tier patrons
the one and only gilgamesh who's the
current most donated
overall champion of the world nothing
but a fan jason wilson
kings eldris anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
actor jessica k lafond hinokami and
water bonnie parks rathu and de ora
floreon
joanne garcia steelers deadly saint and
stern hawkins thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
animepro and becoming a patron today for
as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
amazing people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord where we talk about anime
life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime outbroad link in the description
if you are interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way if you
prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thank you all again so much and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you